- Hey guys how's it going, it's Justine
and today we are in my
kitchen and we are making
a freaking pumpkin pie,
and I am so excited
because I love pumpkin pie,
and I've never made one before
so I'm not really sure
how this is going to go.
I've done a lot of Google
research about pumpkin pies,
but I think what I'm
going to do is I'm just
going to follow the recipe
on the back of this can.
It says it's a famous pumpkin
pie and it makes 10 servings.
So I've got all of my ingredients ready.
We're going to make this
in the blender, obviously.
There's also a problem
because I realize I don't have
ground ginger, I don't have ground cloves,
but what I do have is an
abundance of pumpkin spice spice.
And I don't know what's in
here but it smells good.
So I'm basically just gonna
dump a bunch this in there
and cross my fingers
and hope for the best.
What I do have is nutmeg and cinnamon,
which I kind of have a feeling
this is all in here anyway,
so I don't know, who knows.
Happy Thanksgiving.
Cinnamon, ginger, cloves, in small bowl.
See I can't do that because
I'm making this in a blender
so I need to put the liquid
ingredients in first.
So what we're going to do, we're going
to put the evaporated milk in first.
I hope this is evaporated milk, yup.
Evaporated milk is fresh,
nutritious milk, from which
half the water has been removed.
Wee.
Awe come on.
No!
(cheery music)
So sugar, I'll put you in there.
Two large eggs.
One.
Ah-two.
One tisp, ground cinnamon.
I was surprised, a tisp
is a lot more than I,
that's definitely more than a tisp.
Pumpkin spice, everything nice.
Add a little bit of cinnamon, if ya will.
That's super spicy.
Last but not least we need our pumpkin.
We're using Libby's, said it was famous.
Maybe Libby should make
something for Thanksgiving.
That would be good.
I may have a few new subscribers
who might be a little
confused, about my channel.
Are you a baking channel
or are you a tech channel?
Why are you dressed as a lobster?
These are questions that I
am unable to answer for you.
I am me.
I'm also confused.
Pumpkin is actually really good for dogs,
when they have diarrhea.
(cheery music)
(blender churring)
Pumpkin pie, pumpkin pie.
I mean that's, that's really it.
Well I guess we'll set this aside,
while we prepare our crust.
Now we're going to make
this very special because
I am making a pumpkin poo pie.
Where does the poo come into play?
I got this beautiful pie pan
off of Amazon, it's beautiful.
It's like super official, I've
never had a pie pan before
why would I have one,
because I don't bake pies.
But today, hoo hoo, we're making some pie.
I've got this, it's a, it's
called Immaculate Honestly
Delicious pie crust, oh I don't
know we'll see how it works.
(cheery music)
Look at this.
Oh this is great.
I just have to roll it out.
(upbeat music)
Alexa cancel.
Okay anyway, put myself back together.
Alright here's our dough.
That's it?
Like I just literally roll this out.
Oh it's very cold.
Oh.
You're supposed to just roll out!
- [Man] Is it frozen?
- No, it's just refrigerated.
- [Man] It says, room
temperature for 25 to 30
minutes, 60 minutes if frozen.
Dough may crack if too cold.
Be sure to let dough
set for required time,
before unrolling.
- Can I put it in the microwave?
(cheery music)
- This sucks.
Oh God it's melting.
This was a very bad idea.
I'm so sad.
But guess what, I don't care.
Get in there.
We're going to mold this back together,
and we're going to make this pie
look as beautiful as it can be.
Pinch it, like no one's going
to see the bottom of this pie.
I mean honestly, to be
completely honest with you,
if anyone eats this they're
probably going to die.
So, let's be real.
Look at this, it's looking perfectly fine.
Push this down at the bottom.
So I'm gonna probably open
one of these other ones.
I'll give them hugs, so they warm up.
I'm so upset.
So I'm going to put this
in the microwave again.
Should I put them with this wrapper on it?
No?
Okay, Nathan is shaking
his head, a very rapid no.
I'm just gonna like put this...
Maybe like warm itself up
inside here so I can...
I'm going to pour in the mixture now.
This is very liquidy.
Like is pumpkin pie supposed to be
like a pumpkin spice
freakin' latte or what's up?
This looks very suspect.
Alexa is pumpkin pie
supposed to be watery?
- [Alexa] Hmm, I don't know that.
- See I don't either.
So the reason this is going
to be a pumpkin poo pie,
is I'm going to be using Rosanna's
little poo emoji cut-out here.
Oh this is starting to glisten.
Anyway, you guys know how on pumpkin pies
they always have those
little decorations on 'em,
like festive little leaves.
Well we're going to have
a cutout poop on it,
and I'm gonna bake the
little poop separately,
and then I'm gonna put
the poop on top of it,
and really this is all theoretical,
'cause I honestly at this point,
I don't even know if
this is gonna even cook.
Like this looks like trash.
It looks like I went to Starbucks,
took a pumpkin spice latte
and dumped it inside of here.
Questionable.
Wow.
Uh we've got a problem.
This is so hot, it's boiling.
I can't use this, oh no.
Dun dun dun.
This is clearly not going to be edible.
I have ruined Thanksgiving.
Do you guys remember, I think
it was last year Thanksgiving,
and my one project that
I was supposed to make
was pumpkin bread.
Guess what I didn't do?
Make the pumpkin bread properly.
Alright we got one last try.
This one's too hot.
This one is too cold.
It still feels a little cold.
You can do it, Jenna!
Can you bring me a hairdryer?
- [Jenna] Uh.
I can't unroll this last
little bit because I know
it's going to be too cold,
so I think a hair dryer
may solve the problem.
When Jenna sees what I'm using this for.
I'm gonna set everything off to the side.
Oh yeah, this is gonna work well.
(hair dryer blowing)
A little bit of a crack, it's okay.
- I don't remember grandma
making pies this way.
- Aw I made a mistake.
- What is that smell?
Did you make this homemade?
- No!
Why do you think I'm blow drying it?
So I'm heating it up
because it didn't thaw
and then the rest of them cracked,
you'll see in the video later.
(cheery music)
So to make it the pumpkin poo emoji,
we're going to use this
little pumpkin cut-out.
Cut this out just like so,
and we're going to bake that separate.
(gasp)
Now I made it too warm.
Hey Jen can you come here?
We need to transfer this
on to the pumpkin pie
without breaking it too much.
- Man, does that stink.
- Yeah it's disgusting.
- Wait I don't think
this is going to work.
Jam it back in there...
What happened there?
Okay, let's put it back together.
- Oh you know what?
This is what we're gonna do.
We're going--
- That didn't work.
- To put this here.
We're going to add some of
these little holes here.
And I'm going to cut
this, rest of this off.
Pinch this all together, so like honestly
I think that this will
just merge back together,
and everything will be fine.
I've already ruined Thanksgiving.
- [Jenna] You ruined
last year too, remember?
- Oh yes I've already told them.
- Tried to make a vegan uh pumpkin bread.
- Aw man, this is like soup!
Should I just put it back
in the oven or is this
just like an impossible...
I think it's...
Oh man guys, we can eat the top.
So the directions it says
you're supposed to do
a couple of different things.
15 to 20 minutes you're supposed
to cover the outer crust
which I have a little thingy for that.
So this protects the edges,
like why do I even care?
I mean at this point,
this is an absolute mess.
So this covers the outer edges here,
so they don't get too crisp.
And then...
Yeah I'm not sure, I would
just say don't do anything
that I'm doing in this video.
340, 350, 400, okay I'm
gonna let that pre-heat,
then put this thing in the oven,
and I will see you guys shortly.
A lot of things have happened.
First of all, I think
the only successful thing
that has happened is this tiny little poo
that I cut out of the original dough.
I baked this for about 15 to 20 minutes.
There were a lot of things that went on,
because it was like oh
okay you have to turn
the temperature down to
350, and at 20 minutes
remove the little thing
around the crust and then
do something else and I was
like this is a lot of work.
And the whole time I'm
watching this freakin' pie,
and it is jiggling like Jell-O.
Like my body in slow motion.
So we're gonna take it out.
I don't know what to expect.
I'm slightly nervous, and
I'm actually a little upset,
because I really did try
moderately hard to make this work.
Wow it is crispin' up a freaking storm.
I think I should have
probably taken it out,
like 20 minutes ago.
It's bubblin'.
I should probably close the oven.
Okay, do you want to get
in here and take a look?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like it looks like...
do I have to let it cool
before I can cut it?
You're a pumpkin pie expert.
- [Jenna] That does not
look like pumpkin pie.
- Shut up what do you think it is?
- Why is it crusted on top?
Like all the pumpkin pies I've
ever had we're just pumpkin.
- Look at this, that's our poo.
- That looks.
- Oh did I mess it up?
- No.
- Gosh this is so hot.
There we go that's nice.
- Oh!
Baby!
- It's hot!
- Warm!
Woo, I gotta go.
- Now what do I do?
I'm so confused.
- [Jenna] Oh my gosh.
- But I wanna eat it now.
So I probably have to let
this cool off now oh my gosh.
Can I just put whip cream on it?
- [Jenna] It'll melt.
- Okay well I guess I'll let this cool off
and then I'll see you
guys in a little bit.
Like what happened, it looks so bad.
- I've just never seen a
pumpkin pie like that before.
- [Justine] You've never had
pumpkin pie with top before?
- No like apple pie.
- Oh no you're right.
I don't think I've ever
had a pumpkin pie with--
- [Jenna] That's why I
was like did you make
apple pie or pumpkin pie?
- I completely messed this
up from the beginning!
- [Man] I was wondering what the plan was,
'cause I've never seen it done that way.
- I've never either, maybe
you're on to something.
- Maybe I'm an idiot.
- [Man] Or maybe it's just your version.
- Like I did not even think about it.
I've never seen a pumpkin
pie with a freaking
crust on the top of it.
You're right it's apple pie.
Oh my gosh!
- [Jenna] Yeah but you got poopkin pie.
- Pumpkin poop pie.
- [Jenna] Poopkin pie.
- A poopkin pie, awe man.
Okay well I'll let this cool
off and then we can try it.
We've got the pie, ready and cooled.
God this thing is so stupid,
I still can't believe that I
put crust on the top of it.
Like in my mind, because there
was two crusts in the box,
I was like well of course I
put crust on top of the pie.
Of course!
Oh, that smells good, wow.
Oh wow.
This is (laughing) this is like soup.
This did not firm up, the way
that it should have, at all.
Oh my gosh, I need a spoon for my pie.
(cheery music)
Like I don't want to
try this but I have to.
(chewing)
So.
It's actually not bad.
But this consistency I
do not think is correct,
and all this extra flakey goodness.
Let's try this crust, oh God.
That is burnt, that is
burnt, it is not good.
Look at this, that is super crusty.
Super crisp.
Jenna I would offer you some of this
but I would actually
recommend you don't eat it.
- Why is it brown?
- I burnt it.
Here I'll get you fresh spoon.
You might as well just take
a scoop from the middle.
(cheery music)
It's like alright.
- Yeah it's not bad it's just like.
- It's like pudding.
- Well pumpkin pie usually
is a little softer.
- Yeah but this is like super soft--
- Because it's still warm.
- Oh, look at this,
this looks like garbage.
Yeah just take a bite of that.
- Really gotta get in there.
I haven't had dinner yet.
- Well guys, thanks for
watching if you don't
see me again it's because,
it's because I died
from making a pumpkin pie.
Well thank you guys so much for watching,
happy Thanksgiving, I love you guys,
let me know what you would like
to see me make in the future
in the comments below.
If you haven't already
subscribed to my channel,
do so by clicking subscribe and make sure
you guys like the video,
if you somewhat enjoyed it.
If you didn't like it
just click like anyway,
to make me feel better about--
- I'm gonna have to dislike this video.
- How much time I spent
making this pumpkin pie
and it's not good!
What did I do wrong?
If you guys have any recipes
for me please let me know.
I did so many things
wrong, so many things.
But now I know for the next time,
my next pie will be immaculate.
It will be beautiful.
I think...
if I recall...
Can't open that there
are some things in there.
I think the dough that I used
was called Immaculate Dough.
Do you remember?
Was it?
I think it was, so my next
pie will be immaculate.
This was a massacre.
I'll see you guys later, bye!
Oh man I tried so hard.
Like I'm so sad, like I
actually really tried.
(clanking)
Okay and scene.
(upbeat music)